foreign
this is from Stephen Pursuit he says I
must confess to all my future employers
and readers my college education was a
joke my degree means a little more than
I am patient enough to find a way to
live through four years of educational
farce that was so relatable all my stars
yeah but tell it to the surgeon who's
operating on your grandmother though
it's okay but I'm a believer that
college is a scam be because you have
some people that do need the credentials
like doctors people that work in
medicine Sciences Etc
I did not need a degree for theater like
that's the butt of every joke as a
theater and then an English degree but
it really does make you feel kind of
like a joke you rack up all of this debt
you graduate with honors you've got all
the credentials and stuff and nobody
hires you but you know what's
interesting though even with even with a
theater thing I think
like I have thought about taking theater
classes just because you know I've got
I'm in LA and like I'd love to do some
comedy stuff uh I've been in a couple
plays I've had people tell me they're
like dude you have really good stage
presence but like you need to take a
couple theater classes yeah so I have
like totally have thought about that
before but if I ever took a theater
class I would go into the the thought
and maybe it's hard to tell an 18 year
old this but I would go into the thought
of like there's a risk like if I go to
this theater class it's such a small
percentage of people who graduate with
this that actually do something with it
two quick things one thing that happens
a lot in discussions on like college
schooling and education is we take
principles that only apply to a minority
and then we um transfer it over to
things that apply to a majority so for
instance everyone is sold on the
doctrine of you need a degree to be a
player in the world yes and then we you
know when someone critiques that or
questions that we point out the lawyer
the accountant the surgeon and so on but
it's the overwhelming majority of people
who go to college it's not even close
they're not going to school for law no
they're not going to school to be a
doctor and so even if we just sat down
on the Shelf let's focus on all the
people that are going into debt to get
degrees in anthropology to get degrees
in theater nothing wrong with that with
those subjects but there's something
wrong with the hope that they are being
sold the second thing I would say you
know like if you wanted to go into
theater and you wanted to go into acting
here's why it's so important to make
that distinction between education and
schooling think about all of the real
actors and I Define real actor as people
who
actually have a resume where they're
experienced in theater people who get
paid to do acting people that are like
the people that actors want to be like
right like I I Define a real actor as
when I go to someone who wants to take
an acting class and I say who do you
want to be like and they're not going to
tell me their college professor they're
going to tell me somebody that's on
Broadway somebody that's on TV those
types of people people that have been in
commercials they're teaching acting
classes out there yeah you don't get a
degree in return for those acting
classes but you get to learn something
from people that are getting paid to do
the thing that you want to get paid to
do where the three of us agree is that
we want to help people avoid debt as
much as possible and we want to help
people avoid mistakes and that's what
this whole podcast is about it's about
talking about all our crappy mistakes
and yeah my BS degree was just that it
was a BS degree Bachelor's in science
yeah really yes I did not know that you
were making a joke no it's really easy I
mean he was making a joke yeah but no
really yeah but like it was explained
the joke to you real quick
so but but here but here's the thing
like let me tell you what I got out of
out of that degree though I am the only
I'm the only member of my family on both
sides to have a four-year degree so I
might have like an aunt or something
um but I'll tell you like when I
graduated my mom came my brothers came
my sister came and
um they were like I've never seen them
so proud of me and it wasn't that I was
like oh wow they're so proud of me but I
saw them I saw their wheel like wow if
Ryan can because I graduated like 31 and
I saw them looking I'm like oh wow if
Ryan can make this change at 30 so
that's what I took away from it now for
all intensive purposes
for all intents and purposes I always
get that one wrong
um uh uh it was a waste of money
absolute waste of money but there is
still something I could still take from
it but yeah I think we're all three of
us agree he's like hey before you go
into debt before you you know dedicate
four six eight years of your life to a
degree like make sure you're doing it
very very intentionally don't do it
thinking that oh if I just make it
through it then I'm gonna get out of
college and I'm gonna I'm gonna make a
million dollars a year like that's not
how it works maybe in the 80s and early
90s like that's you know you were kind
of opening some more doors um but it's
it just doesn't work that way anymore
yeah hey Josh I promise I'll be fast
with this and I'm also gonna breathe and
calm down because I get so worked up
I'm gonna calm down I gotta breathe okay
one important thing to think about with
the risk and I use this early when we
had our first conversation on school I
believe is risk is not just defined by
the possibility that something may not
work but it's also determined by the
costs that you invest in something so
one way you can reduce risk is by
lowering the cost of the investment we
don't tend to get stressed out about
buying toasters right because we know
that the replacement costs is easy we
know that if we buy a toaster that we
don't like
we're not going to be homeless as a
result of that purchasing decision one
of the reason why I encourage education
Alternatives is because it's not just
about helping people stay out of debt
but it's also about helping people think
about the process of becoming better
human beings in ways that reduce costs
and reduce the anxiety of making the
wrong decision when you're dedicating
four years of your life and six figures
of debt to a decision you better be
right you better know what you're doing
you better love it you better hope that
you don't change your mind because
that's a high cost on the other hand
when you say I'm just going to dedicate
six to 12 months of my life to getting a
job and getting experience and trying
something new even if at the end of that
period you don't like that you didn't
dedicate five years to find that out you
still have money you still didn't
accumulate any debt you have
professional work experience you have a
network and then you can go do something
else and college isn't even off the
table as an option if you feel like you
need to do that and that's the part of
the discussion I think needs to be
involved it's not just about staying out
of debt it's also about opening yourself
up to possibilities that don't have the
same risk of costing you your life yeah
let's talk about what's obscene here
it's obscene to give an 18 year old
five or six figures worth of debt
that they will now be trapped for the
rest of their lives to encourage them to
do it to tell them their life is going
to be better when you have so many
examples of people who went a different
route because we're conflating School
schooling with education I teach a
writing class I don't have a degree of
any sort and yet far more people
literally thousands of people
have found immense value in the writing
class even though I don't have a piece
of paper that says I should be able to
teach you writing no because they found
value in the words that I write they see
that it's there on the page that's right
and what degree I have or don't have is
irrelevant in fact I've had high school
students take the class I've had medical
doctors take the class and everyone in
between people as uh English as a second
language people who have you know grown
up in America and they're right
relatively well but they want to write
that first book The Rising tide lifts
all boats here and what I realize is I
have a recipe and if I break that recipe
down I can help people understand how to
write better that's why the course is
called how to write better because it's
not about here's your piece of paper now
you're a better writer no I'm not
worried about you being a writer I'm
worried about the writing oh it's much
more about the verb than it is about the
noun I don't care that you're a writer
but if you're sitting down and writing
every day then you are
hey there there's a tweet uh week I I
need somebody to pull up the Twitter
account of Mitchell Earl because I hope
this tweet is pinned but the last time I
looked at his account the Tweet was
pinned and it's it's a statement that
goes along so well with uh with Josh's
opening here but um you know one thing
I'll say while while podcast uh
Professor Sean looks that up is whenever
this topic comes up man
they're always people who
Corner me to have to admit that there's
someone out there for whom College works
yeah but of course don't don't pick on
the poor little kids who go to college
like like don't you agree that college
works for someone and you know not only
do I agree that college works for
someone but there's no epidemic of
people being bullied and harassed for
going to college it is the status quo it
is the more socially acceptable option
and yes it's okay to go to college but
we don't have to take discussions about
the viability of Alternatives and make
it something that we have to apologize
to the status quo before we have but
here's the Mitchell Earl tweet that I
love
it's a dialogue between entrepreneur
Bank student and a bank entrepreneur
he goes to the bank hello I would like
to have a fifty thousand dollar loan
please Bank you've got to be kidding me
your credit score is [ __ ] who told you
this was a good idea student but it's
for college Bank reaches for rubber
stamp say no more
um
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100 advertisement free
[Music]